Thanks. That boy needs therapy. Psychosomatic. Down on the couch? What does that mean? Hi, guys. It's Joel Blackstock with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, and I wanted to give you some news about new developments.
谢谢。那个男孩需要治疗。身心失调。躺在沙发上？那是什么意思？大家好。我是Joel Blackstock，这是Taproot Therapy Collective播客，我想向大家通报一些新进展。
We are putting a neurostimulation clinic in the basement of our practice. That's with the really nice people at Peak Neuroscience out of Texas. And we hope when they're in town, we can talk to them more and shoot a video about the technology to show it to you. But this is a new thing. So what neurostimulation is, which is what the podcast is going to be about today, is new. It's different. So a lot of people may have heard about biofeedback, transcranial magnetic stimulation, or neurofeedback. Those are older modalities. They've been around a while. They're offered at a couple places in town. They all basically use different wavelengths and different technology to do about the same thing. Neurofeedback and transcranial magnetic stimulation
我们正在诊所的地下室设立一个神经刺激诊所。这是与德克萨斯州Peak Neuroscience非常优秀的团队合作的。我们希望当他们来到城里时，能与他们进行更多交流，并拍摄一段关于这项技术的视频展示给你们。但这确实是一个新事物。所以，神经刺激——也就是今天播客要讨论的主题——是全新的，与众不同。很多人可能听说过生物反馈、经颅磁刺激或神经反馈。这些是较旧的模式，已经存在一段时间了，城里也有几家机构提供这些服务。它们基本上都是利用不同的波长和技术来达到大致相同的效果。神经反馈和经颅磁刺激
are washing the whole brain with a kind of white noise that the receptors mimic for a minute, and then that sort of resets the brain sometimes. I don't see a ton of really long-term effects. I think what it can do is maybe stabilize a mood disorder for a very treatment-resistant person with maybe a bipolar disorder or major depression a little quicker than medication can, especially if you're going to have to try a couple medications. I don't see there being a really long-term effect because you're doing the same thing to the whole brain. And sometimes it's calming. Biofeedback is a little bit different. Biofeedback is where
就像用一种白噪音冲刷整个大脑，受体会在一分钟内模仿这种噪音，然后大脑有时会因此重置。我并没有看到太多非常长期的效果。我认为它可能比药物更快地稳定某些对治疗有抗性的双相情感障碍或重度抑郁症患者的情绪，特别是当你需要尝试多种药物时。我不认为它有非常长期的效果，因为你对整个大脑做的是同样的事情。有时它能起到镇静作用。生物反馈则略有不同。生物反馈是指
you have different wavelengths that are being monitored by a cap and you see them visually on the screen. Sometimes it's like lines on a bar graph. Sometimes it's like a little video game where you're moving an airplane or something. But basically it's teaching you to feel what those states of consciousness or those wavelengths, those brain wavelengths, brain functions feel like by showing them visually. A lot of people call it brain training. And you're kind of moving the little things on the screen by thinking differently. You're not moving your body. It's reacting to your actual brain state. So you actually phenomenologically feel what these states are like. And then in doing that over months, a lot of places, they rent this stuff. If you want to try brain training, I know Tal and Teresa Prince at Insights, they rent them and you can take them home.
你通过头戴式设备监测不同的波长，并在屏幕上直观地看到它们。有时它们像柱状图上的线条，有时像一个小游戏，你可以移动一架飞机之类的东西。但基本上，它通过视觉展示，教你感受那些意识状态或脑波、大脑功能是什么感觉。很多人称之为大脑训练。你通过不同的思考方式来移动屏幕上的小东西。你不是在移动身体，它是在对你真实的大脑状态做出反应。所以你实际上是在现象学上感受这些状态是什么样的。通过几个月的练习，很多地方都可以租用这些设备。如果你想尝试大脑训练，我知道Insights的Tal和Teresa Prince有出租，你可以带回家。
But you look at the screen and you kind of practice with it and it teaches your brain that it can switch from different states, obsession, anxiety, you know, more mindful focus and these different things. And so the thought is that it becomes more flexible and research shows that that does do that. It takes a little while. It's not a short-term thing because you're teaching your brain to think in different ways. So neurosimulation, which is what we're doing, is a totally different technology. What neurosimulation does, there's going to be three phases to it, right? So just a little bit of information about the brain here. To talk to the bottom of your brain, you don't actually have to send a super, super strong signal that goes all the way through the whole brain. Because the brain is a series of neurons that are all like an individual
你看着屏幕并进行练习，它会教你的大脑如何在不同的状态之间切换，比如强迫、焦虑，或者更专注的意识等等。人们认为这会让大脑变得更灵活，研究也表明确实如此。这需要一点时间，不是短期内就能完成的，因为你在教大脑以不同的方式思考。所以我们正在做的神经刺激是一种完全不同的技术。神经刺激有三个阶段，对吧？先简单介绍一下大脑知识。要与大脑底部沟通，你实际上不需要发送一个穿透整个大脑的超强信号。因为大脑是一系列神经元，它们就像一个个独立的
little computer processor, and they talk in frequencies. They think in frequencies. That's how they process information. So you can tell what kind of information they're processing or the way they're processing information by measuring the frequency that they're moving information. So you can tell what kind of information they're processing or the way they're processing information by measuring the frequency that they're moving at. So if you just talk to the neurons on the top of the brain, those neurons are going to transmit that signal all the way through the system of the brain because they are all talking to each other. And the way that different structures in the brain function is that they work together.
小型计算机处理器，它们以频率进行交流。它们以频率进行思考。这就是它们处理信息的方式。所以你可以通过测量它们移动信息时的频率，来判断它们正在处理什么类型的信息，或者它们处理信息的方式。所以如果你只与大脑顶部的神经元沟通，这些神经元会将信号传导至整个大脑系统，因为它们都在相互交流。大脑中不同结构的功能运作方式是它们协同工作。
One neuron doesn't really do that much, but when you have a neuron that's in a network, it kind of says, hey, look, this is what we're working on. And then all the neurons in this part of the brain, they synchronize and they're in the same brain wave. And they're all emanating the same EMF frequency while they're doing that. You can have things where someone has had maybe a part of the brain removed. They do that in infants for epilepsy, sometimes real severe epilepsy or a traumatic brain injury. And do that in infants for epilepsy, sometimes real severe epilepsy, or a traumatic brain injury. And the neurons will notice that they can't talk to the part because it's not there,
单个神经元其实做不了太多事，但当一个神经元处于网络中时，它就像是在说：“嘿，看，这是我们正在处理的事情。”然后大脑这一部分的所有神经元都会同步，处于相同的脑波中。当它们这样做时，它们都在散发相同的电磁场频率。有时即使某人切除了部分大脑——比如婴儿因癫痫，有时是严重的癫痫或创伤性脑损伤而切除——神经元也会注意到它们无法与那部分沟通，因为它不存在了，
and they will reroute the information. They build like a new little cable. And so they make a new neural pathway, and you can see that happen. So the brain is pretty resilient. And the problems with the brain not healing are really where it's kind of gotten stuck. And it thinks because of trauma or PTSD or a dopamine disorder that it has to think one way. And that's where you see the majority of dysfunction. Without going too terribly far into detail about this, a lot of our early models of the brain, we talked about it like
它们会重新路由信息。它们就像建立了一条新的小电缆，从而形成新的神经通路，你可以观察到这个过程。所以大脑非常有韧性。大脑无法自愈的问题在于它陷入了某种困境。由于创伤、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）或多巴胺紊乱，它认为自己必须以某种方式思考。这就是你看到大部分功能障碍的地方。在不深入细节的情况下，我们早期的许多大脑模型，我们谈论它就像
it was creating things, like it was doing that that and the new way that we're thinking about the the brain function especially the prefrontal cortex is that it doesn't really do that it's not creating anything what it's doing is it's filtering the information that comes up the brainstem from the body from the nervous system we just can't feel all of that and if you are feeling all of it it can make you psychotic or it can make you unstable. And a lot of times when you look at the dopamine gating theory of schizophrenia, what schizophrenia is, they think now is actually the brain not filtering out all this stuff that it should be filtering out. And because it's not filtering out, it's permeating into, you know, unconscious mid-level consciousness and prefrontal cortex cognition, and that's overwhelming us. So the brain is more of a filter,
它在创造事物一样，而我们现在思考大脑功能（尤其是前额叶皮层）的新方式是，它其实并没有创造任何东西，它所做的是过滤从脑干传上来的、来自身体和神经系统的信息。我们只是无法感知所有这些信息，如果你感知到了所有信息，可能会让你精神错乱或变得不稳定。很多时候，当你审视精神分裂症的多巴胺门控理论时，他们现在认为精神分裂症实际上是大脑没有过滤掉它本应过滤掉的所有东西。因为它没有过滤掉，这些信息渗透到了潜意识、中层意识和前额叶皮层的认知中，这让我们不堪重负。所以大脑更像是一个过滤器，
and it's removing all the stuff that we're not really supposed to think and then focusing on the stuff that we are supposed to think and feel. And so when the brain is stuck, the problem is not like, oh, well, you just took, we think about it like when we have a brain injury, like, oh, you just took some RAM out of the computer, it's missing a part or something. That's not really what happens. I mean, what happens is that the brain starts to get stuck using the wrong kind of thinking in a certain area. And if you
它移除了所有我们本不该思考的东西，然后专注于我们应该思考和感受的东西。所以当大脑陷入困境时，问题并不像——哦，就像我们大脑受伤时，我们认为——哦，你只是从电脑里取走了一些内存，它缺少了一个部件之类的。事实并非如此。我的意思是，发生的情况是大脑开始在某个区域陷入错误的思维方式。如果你
can teach it to be more flexible, then it starts shifting in between these states more easily, and it can build new neural pathways. Because if you think about one thing a lot, you know, that's what muscle memory is, you know, you start to do something over and over and over again you're strengthening that neural pathway and as you strengthen it the the neurons on there the myelin sheaths where they connect they go back and they basically build you know what was another net cable is now a power line or a big fiber optic cable they build a stronger connection because you're using it more and they're going to devote more energy to making that pathway strong that's why things like practicing piano or is effective um so the brain can reroute around things and it thinks in frequencies is the big takeaway if everybody if anyone feels like that was ancient greek and they're lost um the big takeaway is that the different ways that we think the different
能教它变得更灵活，那么它就开始更容易地在这些状态之间切换，并能建立新的神经通路。因为如果你经常思考一件事，你知道，这就是肌肉记忆，你开始一遍又一遍地做某事，你就在加强那个神经通路。随着你加强它，上面的神经元，它们连接处的髓鞘，它们会回去并基本上建立起——你知道，原本是另一根网线，现在变成了电源线或大型光纤电缆，它们建立了更强的连接，因为你使用得更多，它们会投入更多能量来使该通路变强。这就是为什么练习钢琴之类的事情是有效的。所以大脑可以绕过障碍，而“以频率思考”是最大的收获。如果有人觉得这像古希腊语一样难懂，感到困惑，那么最大的收获就是：我们思考的不同方式
modes of thinking are frequencies and that the brain can kind of reroute around damage and repair itself it's just that when it gets stuck trying to think one way, that's what results in the majority of dysfunction in something like PTSD. So the first step in neurostimulation is something called QEEG brain mapping. And so what they do is they put a cap on your head. There's two other places that do this first part in the state right now that I was able to find or that are licensed to do it. Maybe somebody's doing it in their garage. I don't know.
即思维模式是频率，大脑可以绕过损伤并自我修复。只是当它陷入某种思维方式时，这会导致像PTSD这样的大部分功能障碍。所以神经刺激的第一步叫做QEEG脑图。他们会在你的头上戴一个头套。目前州内我能找到的或有资质做这第一步的地方只有两家。也许有人在车库里做，我不知道。
But there's two places that are licensed to do it. They do a QEG brain map, but that's only the first step of our process. So you put a cap on, and it basically measures electromagnetic frequencies that the neurons think at. And so it looks at all the information shooting through the brain for about 40 minutes to an hour. And after that amount of time, there's an enormous amount of data. And there's only a couple people because the technology is pretty new that can interpret the data. A lot of it, we have to filter it out because an eye blink, or a swallow, or a fidget, that all shows up as or a power line,, you know, digital noise, cell phone transmission, that all gets picked up too. So it takes somebody who has, it's half art, half science. You need
但只有两家是有资质的。他们做QEEG脑图，但这只是我们流程的第一步。你戴上头套，它基本上测量神经元思考时的电磁频率。它会观察大约40分钟到一个小时内在大脑中穿梭的所有信息。在那段时间之后，会有海量的数据。由于这项技术相当新，只有少数人能解读这些数据。其中很多我们需要过滤掉，因为眨眼、吞咽、烦躁，或者电源线、数字噪音、手机传输，这些都会被捕捉到。所以这需要一个既懂艺术又懂科学的人。你需要
about a year and a half of experience with the training to be able to read the cues. So somebody has to go in and they have to read that map and they pull the data out and they filter it all out and then they put it into this brain map. Once we have all the other frequencies that are erroneous cleared out, you get your brain map. So you come and you meet with, you know, Jay Michelini or Deanna, or, you know, some of the other people maybe that are training, and they go through what the brain map says. And so it shows you the way that your whole brain is thinking. And so if somebody has like ADHD or an obsessive disorder, you're going to see the prefrontal cortex be bright red because all these high beta, you know, frequencies that
大约一年半的培训经验才能读懂这些线索。所以必须有人进去解读那张图，提取数据，过滤掉所有杂质，然后将其放入脑图中。一旦我们清除了所有错误的频率，你就得到了你的脑图。然后你来和Jay Michelini或Deanna，或者其他可能正在接受培训的人见面，他们会分析脑图的内容。它展示了你整个大脑的思考方式。如果某人有ADHD或强迫症，你会看到前额叶皮层呈现亮红色，因为所有这些高频的β波，
are incredibly intense, that's what's happening. And if somebody is maybe, you know, dissociated or completely gone, you'll see, you know, a lot more low level frequencies. Anyway, and the thing is, too, I'm not a brain mapper. I'm a social worker, so I don't know a ton of, I don't know everything about the technology. And I'd like to just shoot a video so you guys can actually see it happening and hear Jay and Tiana do their work themselves. But you get this brain map, and then the brain map is taken.
极其强烈，这就是正在发生的事情。如果某人可能解离或完全神游，你会看到更多低频波。总之，问题是，我不是脑图专家。我是一名社会工作者，所以我对这项技术了解得并不全面。我只是想拍个视频，让你们亲眼看到它的过程，并听听Jay和Tiana亲自进行工作。但你得到了这张脑图，然后这张脑图被拿走。
And it kind of shows you what's working in the brain, what's not, parts that should be talking or maybe they're not talking. And after they do that, they do something called neurostimulation. And so they build a neurostim plan. And that neurostim plan is completely yours. If you go do neurofeedback, biofeedback, whatever, those devices are doing the same thing to the whole brain. They're washing the whole brain with white noise to reset it. This does two things different. One, it's completely yours. It's not just washing the whole brain with alpha or beta or high beta, because maybe you don't need that. Maybe your brain needs a different frequency.
它向你展示了大脑中哪些部分在工作，哪些没有，哪些部分本应沟通却没在沟通。之后，他们会进行所谓的神经刺激。他们会制定一个神经刺激计划。这个计划是完全为你量身定制的。如果你去做神经反馈、生物反馈或其他什么，那些设备对整个大脑做的是同样的事情。它们用白噪音冲刷整个大脑来重置它。这有两点不同。第一，它是完全属于你的。它不仅仅是用α波、β波或高β波冲刷整个大脑，因为也许你不需要那些。也许你的大脑需要不同的频率。
The other thing that it does is it has 20 electrodes, and it talks to different parts of the brain differently, which means you can do things like build a neural path from one way to the brain to the other. You can kind of tell it what it needs to do. And the way that it does that is that the neurons think in frequencies, right? And those frequencies mimic each other because that's how the brain talks. It's like, hey, come on, we all need to do this together. Let's get over. And it defaults control to this one top level neuron that takes over and then it starts to do that
它做的另一件事是它有20个电极，它以不同的方式与大脑的不同部分沟通，这意味着你可以做一些事情，比如建立一条从大脑一端到另一端的神经通路。你可以告诉它需要做什么。它实现这一点的方式是神经元以频率思考，对吧？这些频率相互模仿，因为这就是大脑交流的方式。就像是，“嘿，来吧，我们都需要一起做这件事。让我们过去。”然后它将控制权默认给这个接管一切的顶级神经元，然后它开始执行那个
functioning. So the brain cap has emitters that emit the same frequency as neurons. So they can actually directly talk to the brain. They're like look I'm a neuron let's do something you know it's like a you know guy going in undercover cop being like hey does anybody know where the neurons hang out anyone you wouldn't have any myelin for sale but they impersonate a neuron and they talk directly to the brain so it's it's a natural process I mean it's work in the same way that the brain works anyway and then they're like okay this is what we need to do. Why don't we chill out? We're too upregulated here. Let's deregulate. Or, you know, these two parts, let's take this information,
功能。所以大脑头套有发射器，发射与神经元相同的频率。所以它们实际上可以直接与大脑对话。它们就像是：“看，我是一个神经元，让我们做点什么。”就像一个卧底警察进去说：“嘿，有人知道神经元在哪里聚会吗？有人有髓鞘卖吗？”但它们冒充神经元，直接与大脑对话，所以这是一个自然的过程。我的意思是，它的工作方式与大脑本身的工作方式相同，然后它们会说：“好吧，这就是我们需要做的。我们为什么不冷静下来？我们这里太亢奋了。让我们调节一下。”或者，“这两个部分，让我们把这个信息拿过来，
let's put that there. And it temporarily becomes part of the brain to talk to it. And then that is able to work directly on your issue that you're bringing in. So there's a couple of sessions of NeuroSim, and then they start alternating, and they do neurofeedback too. But the neurofeedback is not the same as the other kind of neurofeedback that I'm talking about. The industry is a little muddied in sharing terms and technology, calling multiple things the same thing, and the same thing different things in a couple
放到那里。”它暂时成为大脑的一部分来与之对话。然后它就能直接处理你带来的问题。所以会有几次NeuroSim疗程，然后他们开始交替进行，也会做神经反馈。但这里的神经反馈与我之前提到的那种神经反馈不同。这个行业在共享术语和技术方面有点混乱，在几个地方把多种事物称为同一种东西，或者把同一种东西称为不同的事物，
places, and this is one of them. But the neurofeedback goes in and it doesn't train the brain, but it reinforces that neural pathway that we made or that training that we did. So it's a lot quicker than something like biofeedback, which just takes hours and hours of time. I'm blanking on it. Somebody was trying to sell us one a while ago, and I think they said it takes kind of using it at least four times a week for three months or something. This is pretty quick because you can do these sessions. Something like brain spotting,
这就是其中之一。但这种神经反馈进去后，它不是在训练大脑，而是在强化我们建立的那个神经通路或我们所做的训练。所以它比生物反馈之类的东西快得多，后者需要花费数小时的时间。我一时想不起来了。前阵子有人想卖给我们一个，我想他们说至少每周使用四次，持续三个月之类的。这个相当快，因为你可以进行这些疗程。像Brainspotting（脑点疗法），
if you've done brain spotting or heard me talk about it, the processing is outside of the room, so you can't just do it every day. You've got to do it. It opens something up. You feel it for a few days. You come back. It doesn't really help you to just do it every day.
如果你做过Brainspotting或者听我谈论过它，处理过程是在房间之外进行的，所以你不能每天都做。你必须去做。它打开了一些东西。你会感觉几天。你再回来。每天都做并没有什么帮助。
Something like this, you can do the sessions pretty quickly. And for something, you know, there's a lot of different kinds of therapy. We're not abandoning traditional therapy, but you can't talk to the brain. You know, you talk through the brain in therapy. You're talking to the prefrontal cortex and encouraging people to maybe feel the midbrain and get a little bit more mindful. Or maybe when we've built some rapport and trust, we can go all the way into the unconscious subcortical brain and we can talk to the repressed emotion and somatic pieces of this trauma here and learn to hold it and get it out of there. So it's not coloring our thinking and cognition all the time. But you can't talk to the brain. This is the first thing that does that.
像这样的东西，你可以很快地进行疗程。对于某些事情，你知道，有很多不同种类的治疗。我们并没有放弃传统治疗，但你无法与大脑直接对话。你知道，在治疗中你是通过大脑进行交流。你是在与前额叶皮层对话，鼓励人们去感受中脑，变得更加正念。或者也许当我们建立了融洽关系和信任后，我们可以一直深入到潜意识的皮层下大脑，我们可以与压抑的情绪和创伤的躯体部分对话，学会容纳它并将其释放出来。这样它就不会一直影响我们的思维和认知。但你无法与大脑直接对话。这是第一个能做到这一点的东西。
And so there's some really exciting stuff. I mean, I was looking at the STEM plans with Jay and Diana and it's like, you know, when somebody has autism, there's a signal gap. And so there, you know, if a child has an issue with stimulation, like they can't feel hot or they can't feel cold or they can't hear noise, certain kinds of noise without extreme emotional reaction the reason that's happening is because they have no memory of it it's the first time that they've ever felt that and i don't mean brain memory and intellectual i mean somatic body memory they don't know what to do with this i mean when somebody puts an ice cube on your neck the only reason you don't freak out is because you know what an ice cube feels like and your brain has kind of learned to pick them up and put them in a cup and all that stuff.
所以有一些非常令人兴奋的事情。我的意思是，我正在和Jay及Diana看STEM计划，就像，你知道，当某人患有自闭症时，存在一个信号缺口。所以，如果一个孩子在刺激方面有问题，比如他们感觉不到热或冷，或者他们听不到某种噪音，没有极端的反应，原因就是因为他们没有关于它的记忆。这是他们第一次感受到这一点，我指的不是大脑的智力记忆，而是躯体记忆。他们不知道该怎么处理这个。我的意思是，当有人把冰块放在你的脖子上时，你没有抓狂的唯一原因是你已经知道冰块是什么感觉，你的大脑已经学会了捡起它们并把它们放进杯子里等等。
If you don't know how to feel that, you're going to react extremely emotionally because it's new and uncomfortable. It's like the missionaries when they first started going to Africa and they would get blind children or deaf children that were 16, 17 that had been blind or deaf their whole life and then do this surgery and they expected the kids to be all excited, and the kids like screamed and they'd cover up their ears or cover up their eyes, they'd been blind or deaf their whole life, and they'd do this surgery, and they expected the kids to be all excited. And the kids, like, screamed, and they'd cover up their ears or cover up their eyes because they'd never seen this since, and it was too much, and they wanted to go back to the world that they knew. And slowly, you know, they learned how to do it.
如果你不知道如何感受它，你会产生极端的负面反应，因为它既新鲜又不舒服。就像传教士刚开始去非洲时，他们会遇到16、17岁一直失明或失聪的孩子，然后做手术，他们期望孩子们会很兴奋，结果孩子们尖叫着捂住耳朵或眼睛，因为他们一生从未见过这些，这太强烈了，他们想回到他们熟悉的世界。慢慢地，他们学会了如何去做。
So that's kind of what neurosimulation can do for something like ASD or autism spectrum disorders. You know, it helps to be younger because the neural pathways are still growing. It's also harder to get younger kids to sit still for an hour. So that's part of it. We got a cool computer screen and music and YouTube. You can pull up your Yu-Gi-Oh or whatever, pick your poison or bring something, you know, candy, whatever. And so they take this, the thalamus and autism is saying, hey, this is how you feel the sense. This is how you feel the sense.
所以这就是神经刺激对ASD或自闭症谱系障碍所能做的事情。你知道，年龄越小越好，因为神经通路还在生长。但让年幼的孩子坐着不动一个小时也更难。所以这是其中的一部分。我们有一个很酷的电脑屏幕、音乐和YouTube。你可以调出你的游戏王或其他什么，选你喜欢的，或者带点东西，你知道，糖果之类的。所以他们拿走这个，自闭症中的丘脑在说：“嘿，这就是你感受这种感觉的方式。这就是你感受这种感觉的方式。”
This is what it feels like. But there's a signal gap and long-term memory is never getting that signal. So every time the child feels it, it's like a new thing. And they take what the thalamus is saying. They take that frequency and they can stem it with the stem plan directly into memory. And then when the brain mimics that pattern, because that's a pretty complex thing, you're teaching it. When it mimics that pattern, just like with real learning, they hit the dopamine center and the brain gets a little treat. And it's like, oh, great, I did the right thing. That's what I was supposed to do. I got a reward. And so then it,
“这就是它的感觉。”但存在一个信号缺口，长期记忆从未接收到那个信号。所以每次孩子感受到它时，就像是一件新事物。他们采用丘脑所说的频率，并可以用STEM计划直接将其植入记忆中。然后当大脑模仿那个模式时，因为那是一个相当复杂的事情，你在教它。当它模仿那个模式时，就像真正的学习一样，他们触动了多巴胺中心，大脑得到了一个小奖励。就像，“哦，太棒了，我做对了。这就是我应该做的。我得到了奖励。”所以然后它，
you know, it, this is an aside, but if we ever make t-shirts, I'm trying to find some way to make like, you know, cat treats or something, but like brain treats, I thought that'd be funny. We're working on a bumper sticker. Um, but the brain that that's what happens in real learning is like when I, when you're learning music, like we, there used to be all these theories about why music was effective and people were like, well, maybe the deep bass pounding, it feels like the heart rate in your ear when you're hunting or something, and that is primarily rewarding. And, you know, that's a good theory. There are all these different things. Anyway, that's not true. None of them are right. The reason that music is pleasurable
你知道，这题外话了，但如果我们以后做T恤，我正想办法做点像猫粮之类的东西，但如果是“大脑零食”，我觉得那会很有趣。我们正在制作保险杠贴纸。但大脑——这就是在真实学习中发生的事情，就像当我，当你学习音乐时，我们过去有各种关于为什么音乐有效的理论，人们会说，嗯，也许深沉的低音撞击，感觉就像狩猎时耳朵里的心率之类的，这主要是奖励性的。而且，你知道，那是一个很好的理论。有各种各样的东西。总之，那不是真的。它们都不对。音乐之所以令人愉悦，
is that we are memorizing patterns, and we are memorizing incredibly, increasingly complex patterns as we get further into the kind of music that we like. And we do that and our brain is predicting the pattern right it starts releasing dopamine because it's like you did this you did a good job it's learning learning feels good i mean i know a lot of you guys did not have a great time in school i certainly did not until i got to swanee um but that's not learning that's why you weren't enjoying school is because it wasn't learning um learning something like right now if you're going oh wow cool your brain is getting excited because i'm telling you something you don't know and you think that's cool and you're integrating that um and so
是因为我们在记忆模式，而且随着我们深入到我们喜欢的音乐类型中，我们正在记忆极其复杂、日益复杂的模式。我们这样做，我们的大脑在预测模式，对吧？它开始释放多巴胺，因为它就像“你做到了，你做得很好”。学习，学习感觉很好。我的意思是，我知道你们很多人在学校里过得并不愉快，我当然也没有，直到我去了Swanee。但那不是学习，这就是为什么你不喜欢学校的原因，因为它不是学习。学习某事，就像现在如果你在想“哇，酷”，你的大脑正在兴奋，因为我正在告诉你一些你不知道的事情，你觉得这很酷，你正在整合它。所以
when you're learning how to read when you're learning how to do a thing dopamine is being released once you pick up on this pattern to make your brain go oh good job and then keep that information it's why people who learn more have less issues with dementia and trauma and aging and these things, because the brain's plasticity is still new. It's still rewarding and treating itself and building these new neural pathways. There was a, and we're doing way more brain science in this than I thought we would, there is a study from a ways back about Catholic nuns, because nuns are a pretty good population if you're going to do an experiment. And the reason that they're good is that they do the same stuff. And so you don't have to control for that many variables. If you're going to measure, you know,
当你学习如何阅读，当你学习如何做一件事时，多巴胺会被释放，一旦你掌握了这个模式，让你的大脑觉得“哦，干得好”，然后保留这些信息。这就是为什么学习更多的人在痴呆、创伤和衰老方面的问题更少，因为大脑的可塑性依然是新的。它依然在奖励和对待自己，并建立这些新的神经通路。有一个——我们在这方面做的脑科学比我想象的要多得多——有一个很久以前关于天主教修女的研究，因为如果你要做实验，修女是一个很好的群体。她们好的原因是她们做同样的事情。所以你不需要控制那么多变量。如果你要测量，你知道，
PTSD in the general population or something, you're like, well, maybe this guy ate a ham sandwich every day, and that was bad for his brain. Or maybe this guy drank too much beer. Maybe this person had, you know, a pre-existing condition or whatever. You look at nuns, they're all eating the same food. They're all living in the same place. They're all breathing the same air. Their routine looks about the same. They get up. I'm not a nun expert, but I guess if they're Benedictine or something, I can tell you about that one. But they follow the schedule and all of the things in their environment are very, very, very similar. And so it's a neat population to study because you can look at the brain and you don't have to control for a lot of variables.
普通人群中的PTSD之类的，你会想，嗯，也许这家伙每天吃火腿三明治，这对他的大脑不好。或者也许这家伙喝了太多啤酒。也许这个人有，你知道，既往病史之类的。你看看修女，她们都吃同样的食物。她们都住在同一个地方。她们都呼吸同样的空气。她们的作息看起来差不多。她们起床。我不是修女专家，但我想如果她们是本笃会的，我可以告诉你那个。但她们遵循时间表，她们环境中的所有事物都非常、非常、非常相似。所以这是一个很好的研究群体，因为你可以观察大脑，而不必控制很多变量。
So they did this study with Catholic nuns. And when they did it, they looked at them aging and dying. They looked at dementia. And so the only way to diagnose dementia is through behavior. You cannot, to my knowledge, and maybe they invented this in the past two years or something since I, last time I looked, but you can't scan the brain and really see the plaques and tangles. You have to diagnose it with an autopsy. So you can diagnose it behaviorally, but you can't do a physical diagnosis without cutting the brain open and looking at it. But when someone dies, you can do that, especially if they've assigned their body to science. And so with these nuns, they did. And
所以她们做了这个关于天主教修女的研究。当她们做的时候，她们观察她们的衰老和死亡。她们观察痴呆症。诊断痴呆症的唯一方法是通过行为。据我所知，也许他们在过去两年里发明了什么，但我上次看的时候，你不能扫描大脑并真正看到斑块和缠结。你必须通过尸检来诊断它。所以你可以通过行为来诊断它，但如果不切开大脑观察，你就无法进行物理诊断。但当某人去世时，你可以这样做，特别是如果他们捐献了遗体用于科学研究。所以对于这些修女，她们确实做了。而且
they go through and they're realizing some of the people who had the most severe and profound dementia, they look in the brain, doesn't really look that bad. The brain's pretty good looking. So why did they have all these terrible symptoms? And then they looked at other people whose brains looked like real rough. You know, there's tons of plaques and tangles. There's completely dead areas where protein has just cut off circulation entirely and the brain has died and atrophied. And they're like, why would it do that? And the reason that it does that, they go through what they ate, you know, how they lived. Nothing is there. What their genes were, what race were they, where did they grow up? There's not anything in their history that is consistent. The thing that was consistent was
她们深入研究并意识到，一些患有最严重和深刻痴呆症的人，她们观察大脑，看起来并没有那么糟糕。大脑看起来相当不错。那么为什么她们会有所有这些可怕的症状呢？然后她们观察了其他大脑看起来非常糟糕的人。你知道，有大量的斑块和缠结。有完全死亡的区域，蛋白质已经完全切断了循环，大脑已经死亡和萎缩。她们想，为什么会这样？她们研究了她们吃什么，你知道，她们怎么生活。什么都没有。她们的基因是什么，她们是什么种族，她们在哪里长大？她们的历史中没有任何一致的东西。一致的东西是
behavior. The people whose brains were the most damaged but showed no symptoms were nice and creative. Do you hear that? Nice, be nice. And because they were kind and they had an openness and a mindfulness to them, they were still learning. And when you're still learning, you are curious. When I'm trying to hire clinicians, that is the biggest thing that I look for. If you want a job at Taproot, listen up. When I talk to somebody and they know everything,
行为。那些大脑受损最严重但没有表现出症状的人，她们善良且有创造力。你听到了吗？善良，要善良。因为她们很友善，她们有一种开放和正念，她们仍在学习。当你仍在学习时，你是好奇的。当我试图雇佣临床医生时，这是我寻找的最重要的事情。如果你想在Taproot工作，听好了。当我与某人交谈，而他们认为自己无所不知时，
even if they're brilliant, even if they're 100 times more brilliant than me, but they don't really care about new information, they're not going to be a great clinician because they're not going to listen to the patient because they can't even listen to the person trying to hire them. And they're going to learn one little thing and then be like, okay, well, this is what I do. I want to do a hundred C's in this for the rest of my life. And that's all I'll do. And there's something about that that doesn't work because they're not being like, oh, wow, I don't know that. Cool. They're afraid of what they don't know. They're like, oh, I don't know that. Oh, bad. I don't have that training. Okay. Well, wonder. Have a wonder
即使他们很聪明，即使他们比我聪明100倍，但他们并不真正关心新信息，他们不会成为一名伟大的临床医生，因为他们不会倾听病人，因为他们甚至无法倾听试图雇佣他们的人。他们会学到一点点东西，然后说：“好吧，这就是我做的。我想余生都做这个。”而这就是我所做的一切。这其中有些东西行不通，因为他们不会说：“哦，哇，我不知道那个。酷。”他们害怕他们不知道的东西。他们会说：“哦，我不知道那个。哦，糟糕。我没有受过那种训练。”好吧，那么，好奇。保持惊奇
and a curiosity. And so the nuns who's, when they started to look at the brains more, the nuns who, man, I did not expect to go on this much of an aside, but it is relevant. The nuns who were very open and kind and nice, their brains rerouted around the damage. So you didn't even see it in behavior because the brain, even though it couldn't cure plaques and tangles, it couldn't cure the physical damage, it was building these new pathways. And you really couldn't tell, you know, it's like taking a computer that's old and underwater and doesn't work, but you're not putting Windows 11 on it. You put a teeny tiny little operating system like Chrome OS or Linux, you know, your favorite Linux build. And then someone's like, wow, this computer is real fast.
和好奇心。所以那些修女，当她们开始更多地观察大脑时，那些非常开放、友善和善良的修女，她们的大脑绕过了损伤。所以你在行为上甚至看不出来，因为大脑，即使它不能治愈斑块和缠结，它不能治愈物理损伤，它在建立这些新的通路。你真的看不出来，你知道，这就像拿一台又旧又在水下、无法工作的电脑，但你没有在上面安装Windows 11。你安装了一个微小的操作系统，比如Chrome OS或Linux，你知道，你最喜欢的Linux版本。然后有人说：“哇，这台电脑真快。”
And you're like, well, it's a Pentium 2. But the reason that it's fast is because the operating system is less. It's nimble. It's not, even though the hardware is not great. And the nuns who brains had a little bit of plaques and tangles, but not much, those just did debilitating damage because they had no ability to learn, no ability to think creatively, and no ability to reroute around this damage. So that is relevant to neurostem because you can do this without dementia. You can reroute. Dementia is not the only kind of damage there is. You can reroute around these places where
你说：“嗯，这是一个奔腾2。”但它之所以快，是因为操作系统更小。它很灵活。它不是，即使硬件并不好。而那些大脑有一点斑块和缠结，但不多，却造成了衰弱性损伤的修女，因为她们没有学习能力，没有创造性思考的能力，也没有绕过这种损伤的能力。所以这与神经刺激有关，因为你可以在没有痴呆症的情况下做到这一点。你可以重新路由。痴呆症不是唯一存在的损伤。你可以绕过这些地方，那里
there's rigidity and bad habits and neural patterns. I mean, maybe we talked to Wynn Cheps last week, and he was talking about family scripts. We sort of learn how we have to act in a family, and there's a rigidity there. You can undo that wiring with more than just talk therapy. Most people know what they need to do. They just don't think they can, or they don't know how to feel the thing that stops them from changing.
有僵化和坏习惯以及神经模式。我的意思是，也许我们上周和Wynn Cheps谈过，他谈到了家庭剧本。我们某种程度上学会了我们在家庭中必须如何表现，那里有一种僵化。你可以用不仅仅是谈话疗法来解开那种布线。大多数人知道他们需要做什么。他们只是认为他们做不到，或者他们不知道如何感受那些阻止他们改变的东西。
You also can go in and these somatic muscle memories that maybe every time I'm vulnerable, that's bad. I have to, my back gets tight and I have to get angry and my blood pressure goes up because vulnerability gets me hurt. You know, dad said that I was a baby or, you know, that, you know, don't cry. I'll give you something to cry about. And so I'm not allowed to be sad. I'll just get angry, you know. That is one type of connection that can be unwired, you know, analyzed and unwired with the QEG neurostem combination. So, you know, there's a couple different conditions that neurostem can treat. I think that brain spotting works really well for PTSD. Neuro-STEM can reinforce a lot of the changes made there. You can do this stuff together, which is why we're putting it in the same office. I always thought it was like really cool that, you know, it looks like the pathway to the future is
你也可以进去，这些躯体肌肉记忆，也许每次我脆弱时，那都是坏事。我必须，我的背部变紧，我必须变得愤怒，我的血压升高，因为脆弱会让我受伤。你知道，爸爸说我是个婴儿，或者，你知道，那，你知道，别哭。我会让你哭个够。所以我不能悲伤。我只会变得愤怒，你知道。这是一种可以通过QEEG神经刺激组合来解开、分析和解开的连接。所以，你知道，神经刺激可以治疗几种不同的疾病。我认为Brainspotting对PTSD非常有效。神经刺激可以强化那里做出的许多改变。你可以把这些东西放在一起做，这就是为什么我们把它放在同一个办公室。我一直认为这非常酷，你知道，看起来通往未来的道路是
implied. We always want to be a little bit ahead of research. And if you're an academic and I just made your heart rate go up because I said ahead of research and you're like, what could exist before research proves that it's real? The answer is intuition. If I get trained in 13 models of therapy, which I did, and then I do four of them and they work better, then I know that those work. I was in them as a patient and they worked for me. And I tried them on a bunch of people and was like, hey, what do you think about these? And they're like, I kind of like that thing you did. And I was like, oh, well, that was parts-based. That was voice dialogue. there's some ifs type ideas in there too um when something works it works and then research figures out why it works later or how well it works or what it
隐含的。我们总是想比研究领先一点点。如果你是一名学者，而我因为说了“领先于研究”而让你的心率加快，你可能会想，在研究证明它是真实存在之前，什么可能存在？答案是直觉。如果我接受了13种治疗模型的培训，我确实这样做了，然后我做了其中的四种，它们效果更好，那么我就知道它们有效。我作为病人参与其中，它们对我有效。我在一群人身上尝试了它们，并说：“嘿，你觉得这些怎么样？”他们说：“我有点喜欢你做的那个。”我说：“哦，那是基于部分的。那是声音对话。”其中也有一些IFS类型的想法。当某事有效时，它就是有效，然后研究会在以后弄清楚它为什么有效，或者它有多有效，或者它对什么
works for um and so you do need research to point you into the future but research is implying that a lot of this stuff is the pathway to be the future of the profession. And my goal is to put all that stuff in one office. Because if somebody's only doing brain spotting, if I never talked to Jan D'Anna, then I don't know anything about neurostimulation. I can't say, oh, wow, look what brain spotting did in the brain. Or it looks like two brain spotting sessions. And then one neurostim is this new protocol that works. So you can't collaborate. Smart people tend to know a ton about one thing. And these guys are so smart. They're can't collaborate, you know, smart people tend to know a ton about like one thing. And, and, and, and these guys are so smart, you know, they're an engineer and a PhD engineer and clinical psychologist. And, uh, but you get smart people together and then they start
有效。所以你确实需要研究来指引你走向未来，但研究暗示这些东西中的很多是成为未来职业的道路。我的目标是把所有这些东西放在一个办公室里。因为如果某人只做Brainspotting，如果我从不和Jan D'Anna交谈，那么我就对神经刺激一无所知。我不能说：“哦，哇，看看Brainspotting在大脑中做了什么。”或者看起来两次Brainspotting疗程，然后一次神经刺激是这种有效的新方案。所以你无法协作。聪明人往往对一件事了解很多。而这些人太聪明了，他们无法协作，你知道，聪明人往往对一件事了解很多。而且，这些人太聪明了，你知道，他们是工程师，拥有博士学位的工程师和临床心理学家。但是，你把聪明人聚在一起，然后他们开始
to understand how other people think. And then you start to build these cool interactions and understand what's happening better than if you were just sticking to your one little lens. And so I think micronutrients and gut health, not just taking vitamins, but taking like some of the precursors, the raw ingredients for the neurotransmitters in the brain, and then having the bacteria in the gut that processes that, that's going to be a pretty big pathway
理解其他人是如何思考的。然后你开始建立这些很酷的互动，并比你只坚持自己的小视角更好地理解正在发生的事情。所以我认为微量营养素和肠道健康，不仅仅是服用维生素，而是服用一些前体，大脑中神经递质的原材料，然后拥有处理这些物质的肠道细菌，这将是一个相当大的途径
in the next couple of years because you can maybe reduce the need for an antidepressant or make antidepressant more effective where you're treatment resistant. How do you build the stuff in the brain that you need to be happy if you don't have any of the ingredients? You can have the best construction crew in the world, but if you don't have any steel, you can't build a building. And then there's a lot of other things that work synergistically. So it's not just one thing that works this way, but if I take three things together, like if i eat curcumin nothing happens but if i eat curcumin with black pepper and then with vitamin c and then maybe with quercetin
在未来几年，因为你也许可以减少对抗抑郁药的需求，或者在治疗抗性时使抗抑郁药更有效。如果你没有任何成分，你怎么能在大脑中建立你需要快乐的东西？你可以拥有世界上最好的施工队，但如果你没有任何钢材，你就无法建造建筑物。还有很多其他协同工作的东西。所以不仅仅是一件事以这种方式工作，但如果我把三件事放在一起，比如如果我吃姜黄素，什么都不会发生，但如果我吃姜黄素配黑胡椒，然后配维生素C，然后也许配槲皮素
they all build something that is completely different now i have all of it like in my body and that changes it goes to uh i'm not going to go too far into the woods about amino acids but they build a new thing um that does something totally different on the body and can affect behavior and change more naturally. And so neurostimulation, brain spotting, myofascial release and Rolf massage being brought into therapy where a practitioner can help you understand what your body is doing. And then once you map that, you take that into therapy or brain spotting or neurostim and you have a more mindfully way to unwire it. Because if you don't know what's going on with the muscles in the back, if no one's helped you understand that, then you can't really. If it just hurts and that's all you, you can't really start to really understand what's going on and heal it.
它们构建的东西现在完全不同了，我身体里现在拥有了这一切，这改变了一切。我不想在氨基酸的问题上深究，但它们构建了一种新事物，在身体上产生完全不同的作用，并能更自然地影响行为和改变。因此，神经刺激、脑部定位（Brain Spotting）、肌筋膜松解和罗尔夫按摩（Rolf massage）被引入治疗中，从业者可以帮助你了解你的身体在做什么。一旦你绘制出这些图谱，你就可以将其带入治疗、脑部定位或神经刺激中，以一种更具正念的方式来解开它。因为如果你不知道背部肌肉发生了什么，如果没有人帮你理解这一点，你就无法真正做到。如果只是感到疼痛，而你对此一无所知，你就无法真正开始理解发生了什么并治愈它。
I think all that stuff is coming. And so that's what we're trying to build and get in the same office as soon as we can find providers. It's very new and, you know, it's hard hard to build something like that in Alabama. It probably is easier if you're in California or Texas or places where they're a little bit further ahead of the curve, but we're trying to build it here for this community. And so NeuroStem works with these other conditions, with these other treatment modalities,
我认为所有这些都在到来。这就是我们试图构建的东西，并尽快在同一个办公室里找到提供者。这非常新，你知道，在阿拉巴马州建立这样的东西很难。如果你在加利福尼亚州、德克萨斯州或那些稍微领先的地方，可能会更容易，但我们正试图为这个社区在这里建立它。所以NeuroStem可以与其他这些条件、与其他这些治疗方式一起工作，
and we want to find out how. We've already done a couple different experiments on ourselves. Like I'm going to do, I did brain spotting on Deanna when she was wearing the cap and we got to see what it was doing in the brain. The QEG showed that. And so there's a ton of possibility. It's really neat. So with the neurostimulation, it can treat anxiety.
我们想找出方法。我们已经在自己身上做过几个不同的实验。比如我要做，当Deanna戴着帽子时，我给她做了脑部定位，我们得以看到它在大脑中产生的作用。QEEG（定量脑电图）显示了这一点。所以这里有巨大的可能性。这真的很棒。因此，通过神经刺激，它可以治疗焦虑。
It can treat bipolar. It can treat PTSD. It can treat autism spectrum disorder, dissociation, mood disorders, and especially chronic pain. Because a ton of chronic pain stuff, you know, sometimes there's physical pain conditions that the nerves are actually hurting and telling the brain that they're hurting. Other times there's, like, sort of feedback loops that get formed in the subbrain. And it's just, like, replaying the cycle. And so you're feeling this pain. But you can go in and, like, downregulate it and turn it off.
它可以治疗双相情感障碍。它可以治疗创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。它可以治疗自闭症谱系障碍、解离、情绪障碍，尤其是慢性疼痛。因为很多慢性疼痛，你知道，有时是身体疼痛，神经实际上在疼痛并告诉大脑它们在疼痛。其他时候，就像在次级大脑中形成的某种反馈回路。它就像在重播这个循环。所以你感受到了这种疼痛。但你可以进入并将其下调并关闭它。
And so there's a lot of different ways that chronic pain can be managed with something like neurostim, which means that you're less likely to be on a whole lot of drugs and less likely to get addicted to those drugs, less likely to run out of your prescription and buy street drugs.
因此，有很多不同的方法可以用像神经刺激这样的东西来管理慢性疼痛，这意味着你不太可能服用大量的药物，也不太可能对这些药物上瘾，不太可能用完处方药而去买街头毒品。
I don't want to catastrophize, but that does happen to a lot of people with the opiates. We have a fentanyl crisis. Anyway, it's good stuff if you need it. When it's something that's addictive, you want to be on as little as you have to be. And with Neurostim, you can be on a little bit less. So I was going to go through a little bit of how the brain is mapped. So when you do the neurostimulation and the QEEG reads all these waves,
我不想危言耸听，但这确实发生在很多服用阿片类药物的人身上。我们有芬太尼危机。总之，如果你需要它，它是好东西。当它是容易上瘾的东西时，你希望尽可能少地服用。有了神经刺激，你可以少用一点。所以我打算讲一下大脑是如何映射的。所以当你进行神经刺激并且QEEG读取所有这些波时，
it will show like a little picture of the brain. Like you'll see this map and it has like 17 little heads on it. And the heads all have hot and cold areas where a certain wavelength is more or less active and each one of the heads represents one wavelength or one hertz you know going up from 1 to 12 and so it's pulling all that information up and then you get the clinical psychologist to put it together and the waves are these i'll just go ahead and go through those. There's delta waves, and delta is the slowest, so they're going to be vibrating at half a hertz up to four hertz. Anything in that frequency spectrum is going to be called delta, and they're associated with,
它会显示一张大脑的小图片。你会看到这张图谱，上面有17个小脑袋。这些脑袋都有热区和冷区，某个波长在这些区域或多或少地活跃，每一个脑袋代表一个波长或一赫兹，你知道从1到12向上，所以它提取了所有这些信息，然后你让临床心理学家把它们放在一起，这些波就是这些，我这就把它们过一遍。有Delta波，Delta是最慢的，所以它们会在0.5赫兹到4赫兹之间振动。该频率范围内的任何东西都称为Delta，它们与，
like, deep sleep and relaxation. They're very present in coma patients. It's kind of a holding pattern that the brain does, where it's like, all right, prefrontal cortex is off. Just hang out. Don't land yet. The airport's full. And that sensation of the delta wave when it's turned on is this like profound awe and relaxation that's kind of impersonal. It's kind of like you're losing you and going into this rest state of rejuvenation, like you're falling asleep. And so that is one frequency that happens. And these frequencies in different parts of the brain do different things too. You know, a delta wave in the prefrontal cortex is different than a delta wave in the mid or the subbrain. But, you know, to talk about something that has, you know, the brain that has literally 12 trillion connections
比如，深度睡眠和放松有关。它们在昏迷患者中非常明显。这是一种大脑所做的保持模式，就像是，好吧，前额叶皮层关闭了。先待着。还没着陆。机场满了。当Delta波开启时，那种感觉是一种深刻的敬畏和放松，有点非个人化。就像你失去了自我，进入了这个恢复活力的休息状态，就像你正在入睡。所以这是发生的一种频率。这些频率在大脑的不同部位也有不同的作用。你知道，前额叶皮层的Delta波与中脑或次级大脑的Delta波是不同的。但是，你知道，要谈论一个拥有，你知道，大脑确实有12万亿个连接，
connecting in five places. So there's an exponential amount of that is very complicated. This is no one way to make sense of it. So the next frequency spectrum is from the 8 to 12 hertz. And that's alpha waves. And so alpha waves, they're observed when a person is awake, but they're relaxed. So it's kind of a focus wavelength. They're commonly experienced when you're closing your eyes you're practicing meditation the delta kind of deep sleep brain turned off and then the higher frequency waves alpha is kind of a bridge so it's like you're mindfully meditating like you're staying with the relaxation transcendental but you're also pondering it or thinking about it or being open to what's down
在五个地方连接。所以有一个指数级的数量是非常复杂的。没有一种方法可以理解它。所以下一个频率谱是从8到12赫兹。那是Alpha波。所以Alpha波，它们在一个人清醒但放松时被观察到。所以它是一种专注的波长。当你闭上眼睛练习冥想时，通常会体验到它们，Delta那种深度睡眠大脑关闭，然后更高频率的波Alpha是一种桥梁，所以就像你在正念冥想，就像你保持放松、超然，但你也在思考它或思考它，或者对下面是什么保持开放，
there. And so, decreasing alpha waves sometimes in certain parts of the brain is linked to anxiety or depression. So, when you see that way too low, you know, then somebody's so checked out so much that that needs to be upregulated so that the anxiety or the depression can go away um and then improve like raising alpha waves also improve relaxation and stress reduction in different parts of the brain so that's something that may be on a stem plan where they go in and raise or lower this for your unique brain um and the sensation of alpha waves is most people describe it as like peaceful or like calm um uh and so the next is theta theta waves are from the four to eight hertz frequency spectrum anything in there is going to be called theta on the map and they're observed during like very light sleep like a power nap or just kind of drowsiness like you're you're
那里。因此，在大脑某些部位减少Alpha波有时与焦虑或抑郁有关。所以，当你看到它太低时，你知道，那么某人就太脱离了，以至于需要上调它，这样焦虑或抑郁就可以消失，然后改善，比如提高Alpha波也可以改善大脑不同部位的放松和压力减轻，所以这可能是神经刺激计划的一部分，他们进入并为你的独特大脑提高或降低这个，Alpha波的感觉大多数人描述为和平或平静，所以接下来是Theta，Theta波是4到8赫兹的频率谱，其中的任何东西在图谱上都称为Theta，它们在非常浅的睡眠中被观察到，比如小睡或只是昏昏欲睡，就像你，你
fading out you know and the theta may be present during meditation and creative activities, but it's a little bit more, uh, active, like creativity, like drawing where you're kind of zoning out into this, uh, thing that you're doing, but it isn't, uh, like sleep. It's that kind of, uh, relaxation. And so, um, increasing theta waves usually, when you have a lot of them, especially in the front of the brain, a lot of times that's indicative of ADHD. And decreasing theta waves where that's just going away entirely can be indicative of a cognitive decline. And so the sensation of theta waves when they're being stemmed or they're being turned on is like a dreamy kind of introspection a lot of the time. And that can be kind of raised or lowered based on what you need. The next frequency is beta waves. And so beta waves have a frequency of 12 to
正在消失，你知道，Theta可能在冥想和创造性活动中出现，但它稍微活跃一点，比如创造力，比如绘画，你有点进入你正在做的这件事，但它不像睡眠。它是那种放松。所以，增加Theta波通常，当你有很多Theta波时，特别是在大脑前部，很多时候这预示着多动症（ADHD）。而减少Theta波，即它完全消失，可能预示着认知能力下降。所以当它们被刺激或开启时，Theta波的感觉通常是一种梦幻般的内省。这可以根据你的需要进行提高或降低。下一个频率是Beta波。所以Beta波的频率为12到
30 hertz. And they're usually present when a person is awake and engaged in cognitive or physical activity, and they're assigned, they're associated with like alertness, focus, concentration. So abnormalities in beta waves can be linked to conditions like anxiety, depression, and especially inability to sleep. If you are an insomniac, you're probably going to have high beta everywhere. I mean, not high beta, beta just beta and the sensation of beta waves is often described as like a state of heightened awareness uh yeah something it's like the mountaintop experience wave maybe um it's kind of a transcendental feeling when it's turned up real high uh and then high beta waves have a frequency of 30 to 40 hertz and they're often associated
30赫兹。它们通常在一个人清醒并从事认知或身体活动时出现，它们与警觉、专注、集中有关。因此，Beta波的异常可能与焦虑、抑郁，尤其是无法入睡等疾病有关。如果你是失眠症患者，你可能会到处都有高Beta波。我的意思是，不是高Beta，Beta，只是Beta，Beta波的感觉通常被描述为一种高度警觉的状态，是的，就像山顶体验波，也许，当它调得很高时，这是一种超然的感觉，然后高Beta波的频率为30到40赫兹，它们通常与
with intense cognitive or physical activity um such as problem solving or exercise and an increase in high beta waves in the qeg when you see that it usually uh does mean adhd2 or uh in really high amounts it can be something like ocd um so that sensation of the high beta wave is described as like alertness or intense focus or kind of like a tunnel vision type feeling. And you do need it. If it's turned off too much, you can't focus, you can't go into like kind of crisis mode and act, and you can't filter everything out and just get this one thing done um i am looking forward to my qeg but i'm predicting that my high beta is all over the place everywhere i bet that my high beta is nuts um so we'll show my brain map when i when we get the technology
强烈的认知或身体活动有关，例如解决问题或锻炼，当你在QEEG中看到高Beta波增加时，它通常确实意味着ADHD，或者在非常高的数量下，它可能是强迫症（OCD）之类的东西，所以高Beta波的感觉被描述为警觉或强烈专注，或者像隧道视野一样的感觉。你确实需要它。如果它关闭得太多，你就无法集中注意力，你无法进入危机模式并采取行动，你无法过滤掉所有东西并完成这一件事。我很期待我的QEEG，但我预测我的高Beta波到处都是，我敢打赌我的高Beta波疯了，所以当我们安装好技术时，我们会展示我的大脑图谱，
set up and we get all of the electromagnetic shielding done for the room because you can't have cell phones and microwaves and all that stuff polluting the neural EMF spectrum. So I think that's it. I'm trying to figure out if there's anything else that I want to say or am qualified to say because obviously a clinical psychologist and an engineer know a lot more than me about how these things work. But it's really exciting technology. And I've seen people that have done it. And I've seen people that have done lots of different kinds of therapy and kind of talk to them about their experience. And I think that's really how you learn about how the brain works is the experience of doing all this stuff. You know, not just reading 100 books about parts of the brain. That's nice information to have. But once you know them, you kind of know them, you got to
设置好，我们完成了房间的所有电磁屏蔽，因为你不能有手机、微波炉和所有那些污染神经EMF频谱的东西。所以我认为就是这样。我正在想还有什么我想说或我有资格说的，因为显然临床心理学家和工程师比我更了解这些东西是如何工作的。但这确实是令人兴奋的技术。我见过做过的人。我见过做过很多不同种类治疗的人，并和他们谈论过他们的经历。我认为这确实是你了解大脑如何工作的方式，就是做所有这些事情的经历。你知道，不仅仅是读100本关于大脑部分的书。那是很好的信息。但一旦你知道它们，你多少就了解它们了，你必须
start feeling them or else you don't really know what they do. And this is a really cool way to figure out, well, how what somebody is feeling is correlating to a functional space in the brain. It's just neat. So, yeah, that is kind of what we are going to be working on. And if you're interested in neurostimulation, you would just call taproot therapy like you're a new patient, even if you're an old patient, and leave a voicemail. And we'll put you on a wait list because it's not open yet. But the good news is that there is a promo that they're doing. And if anyone gets on the wait list before they open, the neurostimulations are only $100, not $150 for up to 10. So if you want 10 sessions at 100 instead of $150,
开始感受它们，否则你真的不知道它们做什么。这是一个非常酷的方法来弄清楚某人的感受是如何与大脑中的功能空间相关联的。这真的很棒。所以，是的，这就是我们将要努力的方向。如果你对神经刺激感兴趣，你只需像对待新病人一样致电Taproot Therapy，即使你是老病人，并留下语音留言。我们会把你列入候补名单，因为它还没有开放。但好消息是他们正在做一个促销活动。如果有人在开放前进入候补名单，神经刺激只需100美元，而不是150美元，最多10次。所以如果你想要10次疗程，每次100美元而不是150美元，
which saves you some money, you can get on the waitlist. And there's no obligation. I mean, if you don't want to once we call you, just say, I don't want to, but there's no reason not to have that option. So give us a call or send us an email and we'll put you on the wait list. And if you're interested about this stuff and you don't live around Birmingham, but want to read more and find somebody who maybe can do it, there's a whole lot of information on our website. If you go to gettherapybirmingham.com and then you go to the neurostimulation and QEE Brain Mapping page, you will see all of this information. And people have been playing around with electricity for a long time and kind of wondering how it was going to change behavior.
这为你节省了一些钱，你可以进入候补名单。而且没有义务。我的意思是，如果我们给你打电话后你不想做，就说我不想做，但没有理由不拥有那个选择。所以给我们打电话或发电子邮件，我们会把你列入候补名单。如果你对这些东西感兴趣，但不住在伯明翰附近，但想阅读更多内容并找到可能可以做的人，我们的网站上有大量信息。如果你访问gettherapybirmingham.com，然后进入神经刺激和QEEG大脑映射页面，你将看到所有这些信息。人们玩弄电力已经很长时间了，并且一直在想它将如何改变行为。
A lot of Victorian horror is about electricity. Edgar Allan Poe, well, not Poe, but what's his name? Lovecraft kind of takes Poe and then starts to say, yeah, you're into spiritualism, but what if technology was opening the pathway to the spiritual? And then H.P. Lovecraft kind of creates a techno-mysticism that I think is interesting, obviously. Jungian doing depth psychology and putting a neurostimulation clinic in the basement. But they, you know, it's a bit Frankenstein. Mary Shelley's Frankenstein is about what if you shocked the body and then it created this.
很多维多利亚时代的恐怖故事都是关于电力的。埃德加·爱伦·坡，好吧，不是坡，但那个人叫什么名字？洛夫克拉夫特（Lovecraft）有点借鉴了坡，然后开始说，是的，你沉迷于唯灵论，但如果技术打开了通往精神的道路呢？然后H.P.洛夫克拉夫特创造了一种我认为显然很有趣的技术神秘主义。荣格学派进行深度心理学，并在地下室放置了一个神经刺激诊所。但是他们，你知道，这有点像弗兰肯斯坦。玛丽·雪莱的《弗兰肯斯坦》是关于如果你电击身体，然后它创造了这个。
You know, so there's always that we've always been curious about the electricity that is inside of us and and and controlled us. You know, a lot of people in the New Age movement would take EMF readings of the person's body and kind of read them like the aura. And they would put people in an EMF scanner because all of your cells they emit this electromagnetic frequencies all the time and we're just kind of learning how to work with them and what they do. I think taking a photo and reading an aura maybe is not going to revolutionize medicine anytime soon but there is something there and we're trying to figure out what it is. Going all the way back to the ancient world, Greeks, there's manuscripts where
你知道，所以我们一直对我们体内的电力感到好奇，并且它控制着我们。你知道，新时代运动中的许多人会读取人体的EMF读数，并像读取光环一样读取它们。他们会把人放在EMF扫描仪中，因为你所有的细胞它们一直都在发射这种电磁频率，我们只是在学习如何与它们合作以及它们做什么。我认为拍照和读取光环可能不会很快彻底改变医学，但确实有一些东西在那里，我们正试图弄清楚它是什么。一直追溯到古代世界，希腊人，有手稿说
ancient Greeks would say, if you got somebody with a migraine, go out and catch this fish that uses electricity to stun its prey. You know, here's the description of the fish and then slap it on the person's forehead and it'll shock their brain and that makes the migraine go away. Which I'm kind of wondering what fish that was now. It's not an electric eel there, Amazonian. So I don't know. I'm not sure if they ever figured it out. But yeah, we have been playing with electricity for so long,
古希腊人会说，如果你有偏头痛的人，出去抓这种利用电力击晕猎物的鱼。你知道，这是对鱼的描述，然后把它拍在人的额头上，它会电击他们的大脑，这会让偏头痛消失。我现在有点想知道那是什么鱼。它不是电鳗，那是亚马逊的。所以我不知道。我不确定他们是否弄清楚了。但是是的，我们玩弄电力已经太久了，
and there's a lot of different kind of technologies that are going around right now, deep brain simulation, TMS. And I know a lot about it, and I don't, I know a lot about, I know a little bit about all of them. And I think that NeuroStim is probably where the field will end up. Sometimes when people own a patent on a certain technology, they're going to push it regardless, even if they maybe know it's not the best thing because they have a patent on it. You know, we don't have any sort of financial incentives to do one thing or the other. I'm kind of trying to do what I think is the future and what's good for patients.
现在有很多不同种类的技术，深部脑刺激，TMS。我知道很多关于它的信息，我不，我知道很多关于，我只知道一点点关于它们所有。我认为神经刺激可能是该领域最终的发展方向。有时当人们拥有某种技术的专利时，他们会不顾一切地推动它，即使他们可能知道它不是最好的东西，因为他们拥有它的专利。你知道，我们没有任何经济动机去做一件事或另一件事。我只是试图做我认为是未来并且对病人有好处的事情。
And I think this is, I think it'll be really cool. So we'll have some videos coming soon. And if you would like to try NeuroStim, give us a call. And if you want to learn more, head to the website. And if you're in Texas, you can go see Jay in the DFW area at Peak Neuroscience in Dallas. If you're in Birmingham, Taproot. And then if you're somewhere else, check it out and then see if there's somebody near you. Thank you all for listening, and I appreciate it. I will talk to you soon. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我认为这，我认为这会非常酷。所以我们很快会有一些视频。如果你想尝试神经刺激，给我们打电话。如果你想了解更多，请访问网站。如果你在德克萨斯州，你可以去达拉斯的Peak Neuroscience看Jay。如果你在伯明翰，就去Taproot。如果你在其他地方，看看它，然后看看你附近是否有人。谢谢大家的收听，我很感激。我会很快和你谈谈。再见。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。